question
do you guys think that girls wearing
makeup is the equivalent of a man
photoshopping
his dating app profile
absolutely
i saw a really good example of this uh
you know snoop dogg's like daughter
yes like she's she's she's an average
looking lady
uh and
i've noticed you know
she has a very attractive boyfriend a
boyfriend is like some model with a
creative design like you know very very
two different types of aesthetics going
on there
and when when people say
you know that she's attractive they use
a picture of her in a certain angle with
a ton of makeup on
which which is
quite it's kind of funny because if if
you said she was beautiful you show a
natural picture of her doing natural
stuff but you have to use a doctored
photo to make that point which i always
think kind of contradicts itself doesn't
it
i think it depends how much also how
much makeup is being used yeah because
there's i've seen certain um quite scary
instagram like videos where you see
someone without the makeup and then with
the makeup on it's a different person so
there's that level and then there's the
level of you know just trying to maybe
enhance
a little lash and then obviously
sometimes people compare that to a guy's
shape up and you know when women get
that spray thing but obviously it's not
the same still
but obviously there's a difference
between completely augmenting your
reality
and
you know just trying to enhance what you
already know the advice i give people is
if you meet a girl that you're taking a
date and she's got tons of makeup take a
swim
then you see you see what she looks like
what do you guys think is it the same
i think it's like talking you're talking
your mic a little bit i think it's like
when a guy has a beard
kind of the same thing
uh yeah and they shave it off and
there's no change i think there's a
difference between like light makeup
yeah
the girls that cake it on yeah they look
completely different i feel like you can
tell though like if you're like close
they're like crusty yeah it's like
falling off
the one night stands from there yeah and
you wait and the pillow the next day is
you notice the ten pounds of makeup on
your face in their face i'm shocked it's
just about it's quite dark in that one
you're a detective it's like jedi jedi
skill isn't it yeah but personally
though a woman that wears makeup she's
got no right to tell amanda it's ugly
that's true
because remember the man you're
complaining or you're talking about he
hasn't got makeup on that's not true do
you ever you ever hear girls say oh he's
medium ugly i'm like sis that's just
your level
says
like
because girls will sleep with a guy and
they'll they'll think that's their level
but it's not your level he didn't commit
to you you're side chick
but what about the girls that are
prettier they wear a lot of makeup but
they're actually prettier without it i
mean why go through that trouble yeah
then why would they do it i don't know
society they wouldn't they wouldn't it's
not society
they wouldn't do it like girls you get
responses based on what you do so they
probably get more attention when they
wear more makeup that's why they do it
so i'm a photographer right so my whole
industry is women men right people
looking good
so there's
hundreds of women that look and i okay i
guess i'm biased right because
they're models so that they look good
but there's a lot of people out there
that look just as good if not better
without makeup but they still choose to
wear makeup so do you still think that's
fraud
absolutely
you still think it's fraud even if she
looks better without it on
to you
to you
if she's better i've met a girl that
says she can't go out of the house
without makeup on because she'll feel
naked
i couldn't find it i just don't
understand allergic
she is naked in the brain
so if you look good naturally why in the
world you're swapping natural beauty for
man-made beauty that doesn't make any
sense i think sometimes people do it out
of you know this
i'm sorry yeah i think people do it out
of yeah just wanting to conform like i
don't want to be the odd one out there's
this discomfort in
being someone who's different
it's it's also because in my view it's
just another layer of abstraction and
women-like abstraction so so if if if if
she can make it more complicated if she
can add more and more layers to try and
like mis you know put available the
truth she's definitely going to do that
we've got makeup um
what kind of clothes she's wearing the
the the everything it's not expression
though
is it not like because like i
i don't know i don't know when this is
but how long has makeup been around for
because i'm pretty sure the egyptians
will make up pretty sure the victorians
will make up like i don't know anything
about the history of makeup i thought
you were watching makeup is
the 20th century but that's about makeup
in general right how long has that been
around for but it used to be for movies
in the past before i become generally no
look at the egyptians the egyptians all
were like
i don't think it's anywhere near the
level as it is
it's probably just your makeup is in
20th century
i don't think you saw the egyptians like
looking like a whole different person it
was probably just like wings
if you apply so much makeup that you
look completely different then that's a
problem right
it's a scam i feel yeah
do you feel like you look different
without makeup on oh yeah of course i
look a bit better but i i tried to do
like really thick makeup i just think it
looks really bad
personally so if i'm with my boyfriend i
don't wear makeup because
can i ask so from your two ladies
you can contribute to this as well so
why why would you say you wear makeup
i do it because i don't have eyelashes
like they're very light and so that's
why i really only wear mascara usually
or if i have like acne and i want people
to see it
so that's why i wear it but
like i'd be lying if i said not to like
i want to look better
the
okay honest
how about you too
i think for me it's just
kind of like manners a it it's kind of
like
a step for women to look more
presentable
but if it's like day to day like if i'm
with my boyfriend or friends like i'm
not really going to like
go all out all the time because it's
it's just a lot of work but if like a
show like this or dinner
yeah i'm gonna put makeup to look nicer
of course
okay that's asian culture right isn't it
japan and korea like it's seen as just
manners like yeah i mean like you want
to look the best that you can to the
people you
you're meeting
or like if it's like um formal occasion
like of course you want to look better
but if it's like day to day i don't wear
makeup i think it's just too much hassle
personally i think there is a logic to
that actually like probably in the 90s
early 1900s where even men
it was culture to just wear a hat
everybody had a hat like if you didn't
go out without a hat you were kind of
like naked or seen as
um
yeah man is
i can see the logic too yeah okay this
of interest how about you i agree with
that but also like i feel like it's just
an extension of your personality right
because there's loads of like artistic
makeup that you can do
as well as just like eyeliner i guess of
your personality do not all right for me
um
it's a strange personality you got there
i thank you
um
question i also i get a lot of these
questions from it's complicated channel
so you guys should check him out if you
ever get the chance he's a very good
interviewer
why are men shamed for lusting after
women
but women aren't shamed for lusting
after money
are they shamed for busting off to them
you just shamed a guy for lusting after
you harassment you said